the Storm Shadow missile has armor and
bunker busting capabilities the UK
defense secretary says the long-range
missiles give Ukraine a better chance at
pushing back Russian forces on their
territory we simply will not stand by
while Russia kills civilians we have
seen what ukrainians can do when they
have the right capabilities but Ben
Wallace acknowledged the Storm Shadow
missiles are not in the same league as
what Russia is currently hitting Ukraine
with the newly donated missiles can
travel roughly 250 kilometers where
Russia's caliber cruise missiles for
example can hit targets 2 000 kilometers
away
the grief and horror of those attacks
can be seen across Ukraine the governor
of the zaporizo region reported eight
people were injured Thursday including
three ambulance workers responding to
the strikes
how can they make us suffer like this
people have struggled all their life now
they are left with nothing
five months of fighting have leveled
buckmut control of the city means
control of a Supply route to the Eastern
Battlefront both sides claim they're
making progress albeit slowly
anyone hoping the wait for a
counter-offensive would end after the
long and grueling winter we'll have to
wait a bit longer the Ukrainian
president revealed to the BBC that his
troops are ready but they won't be
pushing ahead until more weapons
including tanks are delivered the spring
offensive may not be getting underway
just yet but a new training mission in
Latvia begins on Monday it's a joint
initiative between Canada and Latvia and
Junior officers will be trained in areas
such as responsibility of battle and
maneuver coordination Canadian Forces
are now in three countries training
ukrainians nithu crystal gumancing in
London thanks Crystal